i am aware of media reports regarding
allegations of biological weapons
programs
the united nations is not aware of any
biological weapons programs
with support by the united states
ministry of defence
there was a network consisting of
[Music]
using synthetic biology our military
became aware of the details of the
project
infections using migratory birds
as well as in the newcastle disease
yeah there was another project
[Music]
areas
[Music]
funded the biological projects
experiments were being conducted to
study this spread of dangerous diseases
using
parasites such as licensees
under the leadership of specialists over
the united states who had diplomatic
immunity
russia asked the security council for
today's meeting for the sole purpose
of lying and spreading disinformation
and that is exactly what you have heard
from the russian pr this morning last
month secretary blinken laid out with
tragic accuracy
what russia was about to do
he specifically warned that russia would
manufacture a pretext for attack
and even cautioned
that russia would fabricate allegations
about chemical or biological weapons to
justify its own violent attacks against
the ukrainian people
today the world is watching russia do
exactly what we warned it would
russia is attempting to use the security
council to legitimize disinformation
and deceive people to justify president
putin's war of choice against the
ukrainian people
and china too has been spreading
disinformation in support of russia's
outrageous claims
i will say this once
ukraine does not have a biological
weapons program
there are no ukrainian biological
weapons laboratories supported by the
united states
not near russia's border or anywhere
so here are the facts
ukraine owns and operates its own public
health laboratory infrastructure
these facilities make it possible
to detect and diagnose diseases like
covet 19
which benefit us all
the united states has assisted ukraine
to do this safely and securely in fact
it is russia that has long maintained a
biological weapon program in violation
of international law
it is russia that has well
a well-documented history of using
chemical weapons
it is russia who is the aggressor here
russia has a track record of falsely
accusing other countries of the very
violations that russia itself is
perpetrating and given that and
consistent with our previous statements
we have serious concerns that russia may
be planning to use chemical or
biological agents against the ukrainian
people russia has today brought into the
security council
a series of wild
completely baseless
and irresponsible conspiracy theories
let me put it diplomatically
they are utter nonsense
there is not a shred of credible
evidence
that ukraine has a biological weapons
program ukraine is a state party to the
biological and toxin weapons convention
in good standing
as we've heard
the research facilities
are established facilities
set up to deal with public health
hazards they said
they would not invade ukraine
they then invaded
foreign minister lavrov then said they
hadn't invaded
and he repeated this absurdity yesterday
a whole pack of lies
they said ukraine was preparing a dirty
bomb
that was a lie too
they said yesterday that a pregnant
woman staged her injuries in the mario
paul hospital bombing
that was a grotesque lie the us
the international community have been
raising concerns about the us military
biology activities
they have around the world 336
laboratories
information provided by the us through
the conference parties
bcw the us said they are for
transparency
if they believe the right information is
fake
all they can do is to provide us
so that the international community
community can draw a conclusion by
itself
so we expected
as expected
which according to which a guilty mind
is never at ease
about the container
which became the foundation for the
united states going into iraq